assez humiliant pour cette jeune femme
c'est tout à fait légal Thierry et la
mairie s'excuse comme Disneyland c'était
excusé quand il y avait eu un problème
comme le Louvre c'était excusé et il y a
une députée qui propose de faire une loi
pour créer le délit d'entrave à
l'allaitement moi je suis pour parce que
c'est merveilleux d'aller tester son
enfant en public voilà voilà
[Rires]
celui qui n'a jamais pu allaiter font
des commentaires là-dessus c'est quand
même
pas du tout l'histoire des bancs
spécifiques pour les femmes en revanche
qui doivent allaiter ça ça me plaît pas
du tout ça veut dire que quelque part
exactement c'est la discrimination
après j'aime pas du tout voilà ça j'aime
pas du tout mais sinon voilà évidemment
il faut laisser les femmes faire ce
qu'elles ont envie de faire ou à l'été
ou pas l'été d'ailleurs oui mais
justement il y en a une qui a carrément
été giflée parce qu'elle allaité sur une
terrasse à Bordeaux donc on en arrive là
alors que c'est un geste magnifique et
l'OMS alors évidemment tout le monde
fait c'est un choix mais le MS
recommande l'allaitement jusqu'à 6 mois
donc voilà et c'est légal je ne vois pas
ce qu'elle veut comment ça peut déranger
quelqu'un quand on voit des atrocités
toute la journée alors que c'est un
geste magnifique enfin je comprends pas
que ça puisse déranger un mec d'un zoo
parce que c'est la nature en fait ça
déranger les animaux
[Applaudissements]
c'est la nature enfin voilà on le voit
dans la nature et c'est tout à fait
naturel d'allaiter et je comprends pas
cette espèce de politique qui a sans
arrêt et de pression qui peut y avoir
sur les femmes alors après il y a
manière et manière d'allaiter on peut le
faire un peu peut-être discrètement
voilà mais moi je l'ai fait je le
faisais un peu discrètement j'ai essayé
de rarement une femme plutôt que vous
voulez sur la table ça peut arriver ça
peut arriver
si on voit si on voit un petit bout de
téton c'est pas la fin du monde enfin le
corps d'une femme ça va pas être plus
caché que le corps d'un homme
traumatiser si un bout de sein qui
dépasse quoi c'est surtout que les types
qui sont contre été nourris aussi donc à
la base quand ils étaient bébés aussi
par contre je suis pas d'accord avec
Géraldine quand tu dis que les hommes en
gros comme ça les concerne pas ils ont
on peut quand même donner notre point de
vue on fait partie de la société c'est
comme bien sûr comme tout sinon c'est un
peu un peu chiant
avec les ayatollahs de l'allaitement il
y a aussi des femmes très très bien qui
n'ont pas allaité leur enfant
ce que disait toujours mon grand-père